(audience applauds)
It is time for Drew's News,
your daily, "bleep, blorp, bloop" from the good news robot.
(Ross laughs)
I can't do the robot.
You know, who does the robot the best?
Leonardo DiCaprio.
Really?
The words of Paris Hilton, "So hot".
Well with me at the desk is the hottest man in town,
also my co-pilot, Ross Matthews.
(audience applauds)
Bleep, blop, blorp.
Hi, everybody, hi.
Hi Drew.
I've never been able to do the robot
and when a guy, for me, does the robot well,
I'm like (purrs)
Oh, yeah.
When they do that thing with the arm,
they do the this, and it just swings like that.
Oh, there's something so sexy about it.
Yeah.
What does that say about you?
That you find the robot so hot?
Well, it's a human doing the robot.
'Cause I definitely don't look at robots and get hot.
Oh really?
No.
No, oh.
Unfortunately not.
As much as I believe in animism,
which is, I think, what animation comes from,
to believe everything has a soul.
And I am one of those weirdos who like, the VCR would flash
and I'd be like, "There's a man in there,
like having a panic attack."
Just saying "Set me"
Yeah.
"Set me!"
(audience laughs)
You might be bonkers, you know that?
Might be?
Well, first up in the news,
we're starting with the latest fashion trend.
This is so fun.
The New York Post says that people are showing off
their bagel pride with "delicore".
God, it never stops, you guys.
Local bagel shops are pumping out custom merch
so you can rep your favorite local deli in style.
Here's some examples.
Pete Davidson is on trend here with Uncle Paulie's,
the hat he is wearing, that's a deli in LA.
And then, fellow hottie, Jake Gyllenhaal
teamed up with Russ & Daughters for a limited lox sweatshirt
and then Coach and Zabars got together,
and they had a bagel bag, baby, retailing at $550,
which sounds like a lot of money, but it sold out.
Yeah.
You know, it's not a lot of money for a bagel bag
but it is a lot of dough.
(both laugh)
(audience laughs)
Thank you.
So stupid.
But I love that this wearing your bagel pride
is now a trend.
Do you know how long I've been doing it?
Like this is a bagel, this is a bagel, this is a bagel.
I've been wearing it for years.
That's where I was going with it too.
Like I've got 15 bagels on my body.
(laughs) Oh my God.
But they're just not in the form of fashion.
I know, you need a mac and cheese shirt,
because that's your favorite food ever, right?
I actually went backstage to do a quick change
and I passed by our test kitchen
and there's piles of boxes
of macaroni and cheese, back there.
And I just grabbed one.
I was like, "Yeah, I need one of these today".
Yeah. So I feel,
yeah, Rossy.
(laughs) All right.
Well I need a bagel shirt.
You know my favorite restaurant
in the entire world is Chili's.
Uh-huh, anyone here ever had the skillet queso dip?
(light audience applause)
So put that on a shirt, girl.
I will wear that.
I'll meet you with your mac and cheese shirt.
Well why, can you take me to a Chili's
for queso skillet dip?
Have you never had their queso skillet dip?
I haven't.
I would,
Hello, Drew Barrymore, I'm Ross Matthews.
And I'm about to change your life.
(audience laughs)
Well, we go on many dates, so let's add that to the list.
Next one's Chili's.
Love you.
Deal. I love you too.
Perfect.
All right.
Now I want Chili's, thanks a lot.
All right, next up, more news.
Do y'all remember, this story went viral.
I think like in the summer it was about a singing plumber
who got discovered while working
at a record producer's bathroom.
Did you hear about this?
Well, yeah, he was singing, the record producer heard him
and now the BBC reports the singing plumber, Kev Crane
is getting his own movie about his miraculous story.
Yeah, Kev has been singing his entire life
but it took that one unlikely event
to get him his first record at the age of 50.
And we have a little taste of Kev's tunes.
Here's a clip of an original song called
"You Don't Have To Live Like This".
Before we listen, it's important to mention
that Kev used to absolutely kill it
in a Depeche Mode cover band.
Oh, that does tell me a lot.
Yeah. And you can definitely hear that inspo, right here.
Take a listen.
♪ Watching sitcoms on the sofa which aren't funny anymore ♪
♪ Continental TV stations and I'm getting really bored ♪
(audience applauds)
Yeah, very, eighties.
Very Depeche Mode.
I also heard a clip of him covering a Billy Idol song.
Mm-hm.
And he has really got a beautiful voice.
He does.
And he's super smart because I feel like I can sing,
even though, you know.
And I, the fact that he like was just humming
at a record producer's house, very smart,
because if I was like a mailman who could sing
and I knew that you were a record producer
I'd be like,
♪ Here's your mail ♪
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
You know what I mean?
Hello.
He got that record deal.
He's so sweet too.
I heard that he said like, and I quote,
"I can't believe this is my life
and that my dream came true",
which is just so grateful
and I always appreciate hearing stuff like that.
Totally.
And like how amazing that he was discovered,
otherwise all this singing talent from this plumber
would've just gone down the drain. (giggles)
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
I couldn't even get through that one. (laughs)
I love you so much, it just hurts.
(bright music)